the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program and do not
necessarily reflect the views and
opinions of 8 news now or next our media
group
tonight on politics now keeping a roof
over nevadan's heads
the program meant to help renters and
landlords as the eviction moratorium
is lifted plus i'm multi-layered
i also know how to kick off the heels
throw on some boots and get some stuff
done
republican senate candidate shirelle
mendenhall talks to us about her
campaign
i would love to see policies that bring
back manufacturing to
the u.s and congressional candidate
carolina serrano answers questions about
immigration policy and
working on the trump campaign
[Music]
from eight news now this is politics now
keeping people off the streets and money
in landlords pockets is the goal of the
legislature as the eviction moratorium
is lifted
thanks for joining us i'm vanessa murphy
john is off tonight
the eviction moratorium lifts in less
than an hour
governor sisilak and other leaders are
promoting the rental assistance program
created by assembly bill 486 it prevents
tenants from being evicted if they have
proof they filed a rental assistance
application
the court places a hold on the case and
arrangements are made for the landlord
until the application goes through
landlords who own single family homes
can also apply for assistance through
the program
as the pandemic has changed and evolved
so has our approach to the moratorium
and we've been able to build out rental
assistance programs
with state and county partners mediation
programs with the court system
and most recently by partnering with the
nevada legislature
to create a so-called glide path for
evictions
it's important to note in order to
qualify for this you have to apply for
rental assistance so
leaders recommended applying now the
county is processing
eight hundred to one thousand
applications a week
there are currently eight thousand
waiting to be processed
the county said it has paid out 165
million
in rental and utility help to about
ninety thousand programs in the last
year
we have more info on the program at
eight newsnow dot com
a congressional committee is looking
into companies that evicted tenants
during the moratorium
including one here in southern nevada
south carolina democratic congressman
james clyburn
points to court records which revealed
that some large corporate landlords
have evicted many tenants during the
covid19 pandemic
congressman clyburn says the las
vegas-based group
siegel group filed around 570 eviction
orders
during the moratorium that's despite
receiving
millions of dollars in federal rental
assistance money
congress has taken action to ensure that
reynolds
experience and hardship can receive
financially up
to stay in their homes of course the
ultimate recipient
of these funds or the landlords
to whom rent is paid the federal
moratorium runs out this weekend
siegel group will still have to provide
more information
on how many evictions they followed
through with to the committee
if you are in danger of being evicted
there are resources
we have information again at
eightnewsnow.com
well the masks are back in las vegas
everyone now has to wear a mask
indoors whether they are vaccinated or
not the state is following the cdc's
latest recommendations
which applies to counties with at least
50 cases per
100 000 people right now clark county's
rate is about four and a half
times that we're one of 12 counties in
the state
where the new mask mandate applies
clark county is considering paying
people 100
each to get vaccinated that will not
include people who have already gotten
the vaccine
commissioner tick sega bloom says the
county could budget 10 million dollars
from the hundreds of millions it
received
in federal coronavirus relief that would
cover 100
for one hundred thousand people in clark
county getting the vaccine
commissioner sega bloom says more and
more private companies are requiring
vaccines
or proof of a negative test
the reality is employers are going to
start saying we want you to either
be vaccinated or get tested on your own
dime
every week or twice a week so i mean
there are going to be some financial
penalties involved whereas if we give
you this
hundred dollars then you make money as
opposed to have to pay money
the commission will talk about this at
tuesday's meeting
nevada senator catherine cortez masto
has gathered a big war chest for next
year's senate race
the democrat has raised about 11 million
dollars so far this year
two republicans have filed to run
against her reno wounded warrior veteran
sam brown
and sherelle mendenhall she's a former
miss nevada 2020 and miss california and
runs a talent agency
i talked with mendenhall to ask about
the senate race and where she stands
on issues what's your stance on
immigration and do you support building
a wall
um i believe that there is a great
process for people to come into this
country and that needs to be adhered too
i do believe we need to build the wall
we're at you know the last number i saw
was over 700
as far as you know refugees coming to
the border uh we have drugs coming over
we have crime
and uh as a people we're trying to take
care of our own right now the people
who've come in here legally and
it's not enough we're like like you just
mentioned earlier you know about
stimulus and giving money
uh you know the implications of people
going out on the streets so
i believe we need to protect our border
have a process adhere to that
and then we can start being stronger as
a country and then we can help and give
aid to people that are in trouble
what's your stance on daca daca i'm
sorry i'm not familiar with daca what's
the most
important issue for you
um our freedom
i would say that our freedom is the
biggest thing and when i
you know kind of uh was grappling about
running for u.s senate
i was like what am i going to do
differently than anyone else
and i see just so many things flying on
social media and i want to build yet
another metaphoric wall
around our rights and our privileges uh
for instance
i believe the government is two
protectants to serve just like
you know our police and before
phones were only in our tele you know in
our homes they weren't in cars
and so later when they were causing
accidents that's when
they needed to step in and put a law in
place to protect us
from you know not driving recklessly i
think it's you know the
the same thing now we need to build
metaphoric walls around things we didn't
know we needed to protect
for instance i love the role of a mom
a she a woman i don't want those rights
taken away
in our school system education in
government
i don't mind anybody coming up with
whatever you'd like to be called
in addition but i want to make sure my
rights to be
called a she a her a woman are protected
the right to to assemble churches you
know coming together i'm i love going to
church
and i think that people need hope in a
time like this
how do you feel about the current uh
miss nevada winner being transgender
um so for me uh something that's really
important is that we adhere by rule so
throughout all of history
you know the pageant has had in their
roles you need to be a natural-born
woman
so i i don't know that that was changed
beforehand so i really think that that
should be something that's looked at
you know because that means that the
person who did win uh
obviously they thought that person was
the right person but we need to go back
to the rules
that were set specifically to run in
this pageant that you be a natural born
woman
anything else you feel like people
should know about you personally
personally um i think that
something that's important is to not
judge a book by its cover you know i
i up until this point so many people are
kind of desperating
and kind of seeing from the outside
instead of taking the time to get to
know me
i'm multi-layered i also know how to
kick off the heels
throw on some boots and get some stuff
done so whether it's building i'm going
to be in there
demolishing or or putting you know walls
up i'll do whatever it takes
um so i think that's the biggest thing
to understand for people who will watch
this interview
um they may be surprised that you
weren't familiar with daca it's
something that affects many people here
um
what do you want to address about that
do you think you maybe have more work to
do
to be taken seriously and and jump into
the race
um so i look at it as this you know when
i went to this i knew that i wasn't
going to know everything about
every single uh you know question that
i'm asked
and i see it as i have people around me
for the right reason i'm going to
appoint them they're going to advise me
and when it comes time for me to make
a decision on that i am going to
personally do that deep dive to make
sure i'm making the right decision for
the people
taking me seriously i believe that you
know my past
shows that i'm a get it done kind of
person so when that scenario arises i
will
address it and do the right thing for
the people
we have that full interview with her on
eightnewsnow.com look for the politics
tab
we asked her about her support for
president trump and her stance on
federal lands
and we'll keep putting interviews up
there as we get her opponents
as well the nevada press association and
the state aclu are suing to ensure
reporters can cover an upcoming
execution convicted murderer zane floyd
is scheduled to be put to death later
this year
with a never-before-used drug cocktail
i talked with aclu of nevada attorney
chris peterson about the lawsuit
so tell me what the goal of the lawsuit
is
well the goal is transparency um we have
a historic execution
that the state is trying to move forward
with it's historic in the sense that
the state of nevada hasn't executed
anyone in the last 15 years
it's historic in the sense that the last
legislative session
saw a bill get through the house that
was trying to abolish the death penalty
and it's also historic in that they're
experimenting with a new
drug cocktail and throughout the history
of this country and other jurisdictions
when there have been experimentation
with drug cocktail
there's been some pretty disturbing
results so
we're representing the press and the
press access to the execution itself
because the press acts as a proxy for
the public they observe what's going
on and they report out what's happened
during the execution
and in executions where there's a decent
chance that something will go wrong
and in executions in the past where
something has gone wrong the
media and the press have played a really
important role to let the public
know hey this didn't go as planned i
think it's interesting because in nevada
we often
hear leaders when questioned about
transparency
say that they are all for transparency
but when it comes down to it for
reporters on the ground
we are often denied basic information do
you think this is just
another example so i don't necessarily
want to talk
about other things outside the context
we're working with here but i do
think that when you look at government
and this is something going
to what's going on right here is that
it's understandable that any government
agency is going to be worried about how
they'll
look when they're doing something so
sensitive like executing somebody
when you're killing someone in the name
of the public you don't want
there to get out that you didn't do this
properly or didn't look right
and but the reality though is that the
government doesn't have a right
to simply hide away where it fails
right and it can't just block the public
from seeing what's happening
and it's particularly important in
situations where the state is using its
power and the most pure and
serious way possible in killing one of
our citizens
so it's understandable
why the government would not want to be
transparent and why they would pay lip
service to that
but in fact not want to be transparent
but the reality is the constitution
requires them to be transparent
we'll stay on top of this case and bring
you any updates i've also put in a
request
to cover the execution running on
immigration
everybody knows that if you have an open
border then you really aren't protecting
the citizens of this country
up next we talk with republican
congressional district 4 candidate and
trump supporter carolina serrano
plus rebuilding the country is it
possible congress finally has an
infrastructure deal we'll tell you
what's in the works
guys only a jack in the box
welcome back to politics now
incumbent congressman stephen horsford
has drawn a few republicans planning to
run against him one is carolina serrano
who's a colombian-american born in the
u.s
she worked on the trump campaign in
nevada and she's a unlv
graduate turns out she was also once an
intern here at channel 8.
john langler talked with her about her
campaign
you've been supported notably you've
gotten some donations already from steve
nguyen
how did that happen um and obviously
given mr winn's recent
history did you have any hesitation
about taking his donations
i didn't because i worked for winning
encore for almost eight years
and i would say in my 13 years in the
service industry those eight years were
the best ones
and so having his support means a lot i
have a lot of respect for what his
vision and how he's changed las vegas so
i'm happy to have it
you just discussed about your connection
with folks who work in the service
industry in las vegas
we've been through such a difficult time
with the pandemic and the resorts were
shut down for such a long time
what do they need in your opinion what
do they need to get back on their feet
to find employment or if they're already
employed
how to get back on even terms i think
that they need
other options besides the service
industry like i said i mean
it's great for a bit of time but it
doesn't have that longevity that you
need in order for you to be able to
build a home have a family have you know
create wealth i would say so i think
that there's just other options outside
the
service industry would be good for them
so so from a policy standpoint then
what is that what does that look like in
terms of getting them out of the cycle
of the service industry
so i would say you know hospitality is
great if if you want to stay in it but i
would say
i would love to see policies that bring
back manufacturing to
the us right because we don't really
produce much here in the us
and i think you know one of the
industries that i would love to see come
down here would be the fashion industry
i think it would be
such a great place to have that industry
here in vegas where
vegas is kind of this fancy glitzy place
you know your announcement you spoke a
lot about immigration
and uh bill finishing the wall um why is
that such an important issue
why do you think the wall needs to be in
your words finished well i think it's
always been an important issue i mean i
voted democrat and
before they were always about protecting
the border and protecting the country i
think
everybody knows that if you have an open
border then you really aren't protecting
the citizens of this country right it
just becomes
chaotic so the border wall is important
and then there also needs to be a total
immigration overhaul because also the
people who are coming here to
have a better life for themselves
they're not benefiting from an open
border either because each time
a new crop comes in that's lower wages
for
for big business and not beneficial to
the people who are trying to make it
when you say open border the border
isn't necessarily open obviously there
are
there it's not is open a fair way to
describe our borders right now
yeah because i mean if you go down to
like texas i love road tripping so i've
been down to texas arizona
it's vast lands and you see people
crossing through
where there is in a border there's no
barrier right
and so yeah i mean dhs we know is
overwhelmed
and so i would say that they're
releasing a lot of people into the
country
and they have no date to show up most
people don't show up to the dates
so it's a problem you helped support
former president trump in his
re-election campaign
uh how much of that experience would you
bring into
a a primary and a general election
campaign how much do you lean on
the former president do you still
support him do you think he should still
be president
well obviously i worked on his campaign
it was a great experience so yes i
support the president
um i think that that experience is one
of the best experiences and i would say
that everyone should
knock doors in their community because
you find out that you have a lot more in
common
with your neighbor than you think and so
i think there's a lot more in common
between
people who are trump supporters and
people who are bernie supporters and you
could
bring them together on certain issues
we have that full interview up at eight
newsnow dot com
so far she's raised about fifty thousand
dollars for her campaign
her other republican opponent so far is
sam
peters putting out the flames
we need more body as bodies and we need
more air support
up next the changes steve sisilak and
other western governors want to see made
to how we tackle wildfires in the west
plus do we finally have a deal our
washington d.c bureau breaks down what's
in a deal on our country's important
infrastructure
we are live
now the governors of nevada and
california are
asking the federal government for more
help and money to fight wildfires
they made the comments while touring the
damage from the tamarack fire in
gardnerville nevada
that fire started on federal land in
california
then spread to nevada it has forced 16
thousand people out of their homes both
governors say they are having a
conversation with president biden
later this week this may sound like deja
vu but congress
is one step closer to closing a deal on
the president's massive
1.2 trillion dollar infrastructure plan
a procedural vote passed with 67 yeses
in the normally split senate as it
stands the bill contains 550 billion
dollars in new spending
for public works projects members of
both parties say they believe
a final deal will happen at a time when
washington seems broken
this group of members behind me came
together each of us are deeply committed
to demonstrating to the country and to
the world
that our government can work and it can
work for the people of the united states
of america
john langler talked with our washington
d.c bureau correspondent alexandra
lamone about the next steps for the bill
and what to expect before this it had
only been a small group of bipartisan
senators that had been working on the
deal behind the scenes so this makes the
process
more official and more likely to head on
the road to
actually being passed but it doesn't
guarantee that
the full senate still has to come to an
agreement on this one trillion dollar
proposal
and then the measure would need to get
60 votes in order to pass in the u.s
senate
well alex the president biden top
democrats they had much more ambitious
plans 3.5 trillion dollar package they
talked about with
human infrastructure where do things
stand on that
aspect of the discussion right that was
a really sweeping proposal that the
president
and top democrats want to pass that
includes investments in things like
clean and green energy across the
country
and also in those human infrastructure
measures that you mentioned like
free pre-k education and community
college
for all students the democrats were
hoping to pass that
separately with a process called budget
reconciliation
that would only require 50 votes in
order for that to pass
in the senate rather than 60 well it
looks like that
is in jeopardy now too because
democratic senator kirsten cinema of
arizona said
she does not support the idea of
spending 3.5
trillion dollars i mean that is just a
massive number so she says she is not on
board
and democrats need every single democrat
on board so
they are now forced to work with her to
either try to scale
back or rework the package into
something that she might support
if they want any hope of passing that at
all
we'll see where things go on capitol
hill alex lemon thank you for joining us
you appreciate it
politics now
southern nevada gmc dealers
you're watching politics now
so earlier this week i did a story about
a man who's now living in las vegas but
working in southern california
it's about a four-hour drive he's been
doing for more than a year
the dmv told us that in the first six
months of 2021 more than 22 000
californians
turned in their licenses and ids in
nevada you can check out that story at
our website eightnewsnow.com it's gotten
a lot of comments from people
not too happy about the californians
moving to nevada tell us what you think
thanks so much for joining us at
politics now